to ponder during this quarantine is
there any scientific proof that there is
an afterlife I would say no no this
close to becoming a Christian join
yesterday tomorrow and the rapture I
would say no but as a science guy are
you spiritual or no no trouble is what
the trouble is that we are made out of
stuff and at a fundamental level we know
how that stuff works and we also kind of
know I mean we don't know how the brain
works but it's a fair hypothesis that it
just works by the interaction of all the
stuff that's like in this section of
space right here all of this stuff
together makes me me and so the concept
of like what happens once that stuff
stops working the way it's currently
working and what happens once it starts
like disintegrating and you know dust to
dust that sort of thing I just have a
hard time imagining something that goes
on after that do you not I mean because
like we are clearly stuff yeah I think
it like what if we could discover what
what if we could find something that
wasn't just this stuff I mean we know in
our universe there's dark energy and
dark matter those are things we don't
understand and it could be that those
things are Souls but let me say the
probability of that is basically zero
he's up for a second like maybe I've
been thinking about like what if I wrote
like a sci-fi novel where we find some
other substance you know that like maybe
it makes up dark matter let's say and
this stuff
strangely interacts with the matter in
our brain and such that that stuff
actually has free will and you know you
could you could write a story about this
oh that sounds [ __ ] great yeah so far
that's just crazy science fiction right
now would it be more plausible that we
are living in a matrix I personally I
don't buy the whole matrix thing but
okay
you know it's possible yeah anything's
possible but but it's just like what's
you would secrete a matrix it has to be
more complicated than everything that we
see here already so it's like you just
have to postulate extra levels of
complexity on top of it it's kind of
like people who want to postulate a god
and be like well how did the universe
start and and my answer is like I don't
know it just started and they're like
well that's not satisfying I have a
perfect explanation there was a dude who
just started it oh yeah no because
you've added a level of complexity above
just everything we see now you've added
an extra dude like how did they do solve
the problem level yeah it's it's the
fear of death how religions start I
believe I think there was two things
yeah I think it was for powerful people
to control people mm-hmm they use
religion to control the masses you can
see that in our today's culture yeah and
then secondly it's the fear of death you
know it's like and can I offer you a
third a third is there was just stuff we
didn't know how it worked
you know like lightning that's crazy
volcanoes that's nuts
rain when does it happen when does it
not like all of this sort of stuff like
we are like you know floating on this
tide of uncertainty and chaos and yeah
what do our monkey brains do but try to
imagine a reason why everything happens
to me the right where you get this Wow
it's it's kind of depressing it's the
opposite for me I've always like reveled
in the fact that everything like Bobby
is is a lot more spiritual than me I'm
an atheist so I think it's a very
romantic way like I think of science in
the very romantic way like how can every
all those little things create the
perfection that is this like that to me
is enough I don't need a man up top to
have created this the fact that it
created itself is more wonderful than
any other concept I can I can believe in
its wondrous you know wondrous but my
problem is a personal issue is that for
me you know you know I'm I've been sober
you know and
you know in in the program that I belong
to we believe that a higher power has
removed you know mean this obsession
with drugs and I really believe that in
its in a sense because I don't think
about it or I don't know it's not an
option for me it's like completely out
of my you know of my mind and my soul I
don't really it's not a part of my life
but my point is is that without that
that factor right I might use again you
know in its that's my fear is is that
there are parts of me that believe what
you believe
Derek but I can't afford to believe that
because I don't want to do drugs again
yeah because yeah yeah you know I I know
that I've tried to self-will it right
and I tried to control it and it doesn't
work for me the only way it works is if
I believe and I pray and I believe that
a higher power has removed it from me
yeah you know and that's you know so
when it comes to science and it is a
dilemma with me because I'm also a guy
that likes to think and I like to think
things through and I want to be logical
and sensible about certain things and I
you know I I believe in science and I
think without science this whole ordeal
with this pandemic were and we'd be
[ __ ] I mean I I lean toward people
like you in situations like this because
that's what I really believe I don't
believe in you know I wouldn't go to a
church like they did yesterday like a
crazy person right that's crazy
right I kinda lean towards science even
though I'm a spiritual guy well then we
should ask Derek your next hard-hitting
question which one's that number five
well this is your question no question
okay okay